okay four people joining this livestream
this is one of a series of meetings that
we're doing to figure out what functions
in Wolfram language that have been
tagged as experimental we can
potentially make non-experimental for
our upcoming release so this will be a
whole collection different kinds of
things we're gonna start with text
search here so you guys really seriously
think we're ready to do experimental
eyes this did we resolve the question of
what the search results are supposed to
look like discussion about consistency
in search results you know so far that
is at a very early stage of planning and
so we don't know how that will impact
excels design so that is a big thing to
take into account if we are going to be
experimental eyes desert well which is a
good argument not to so let's try to we
need to move that forward before we can
do experimental eyes it's probably going
to change the output okay so I think
that's the end of that story has to stay
experimental for now do you disagree no
okay then we need to what we need to
move forward on that issue of figuring
out do we have another meeting scheduled
about that particular issue do you know
okay so we need to get such a meeting
and try and move it forward or you guys
need to move it forward without me if
that would be even better yeah
we're the group okay okay fine so within
let's say within a week or two let's try
to meet about this because it'd be great
to resolve this before version 12 and so
we can be experimental eyes this makes
sense the current is to use data set so
this is worth this okay let's let's work
through the different cases we know
there I know I know
so there are multiple cases for web
image search Wikipedia search text so on
so we met once about this that's please
got another meeting and we need to
figure out who is going to be leading
this from a project management point of
view is it is it Matt is it somebody
else what's the story okay but the
important thing is that we need to
actually get make make progress on this
particular item fair yep
okay great all right I think that's it
for you guys
Chiara and Nikolas if you unless there's
anything there's anything else on this
list for you guys no we don't have the
web crawl story yet no okay terrific
all right oh thanks
okay audio so we have a lot of the audio
functions already non-experimental right
yes and the reason you
why are we what is the audio stream
anyway this is the handle to an audio
stream to an audio object or an input
device that you can play pause stop
record from and so forth and how does
this relate to any of the other such
objects for network packet capturing and
God knows what else that we might have
that a similar kinds of you know
indirect handles to players we don't not
completely figured out right no no and
one thing as the note says we added in
eleven three is they capture streams so
all your stream of input device reads
from a device for an unknown amount of
time and goes on okay and that bad I
think has not completely figured out we
haven't quite worked out the real-time
audio processing yet which is probably
going to depend this design is done well
so the whole family we suggest we keep
experimental but what about audio
captures and audio capture something
fairly real by now it is the only reason
that I suggest we keep it still
experimental is so that we figure out
the storage location why does it matter
to users oh I see this one
captures into a file as opposed to what
by default I'm not well default it just
goes somewhere that is not as documented
a Wolfram audio directory on their
dollar user document directory and I
think overall in the system we are not
consistent and where we are storing
these Wolfram language generated assets
I think it should go in the local object
store we've talked about that that's
that's not what from an LCC point of
view is agreed upon either okay I think
that's where it should go
I mean can we inventory you know we're
generated files go I know that they can
go to the temp directory they can go to
the local object store where else can
they go documents or this dollar user
documents directory export I think
rights in that as well
why would export write something there
or no export rights it in directory
yeah writes it in the current directory
carried directory yes okay I mean we
kind of just need to UM listen I have a
project I don't think my mentoring is
complete and I sent it to eat I a long
time ago but as I said I don't think we
all agree on where these things should
be placed that no one has to okay let's
just inventory where things get where
things put stuff like we can look at you
know my dollie user documents directory
and see what's there and see whether
that you know
yeah I mean which I don't even know
which version I'm running here but let's
do this one here um let's say
Dola user documents directory okay and
now let's do file names of that star
star coma you know we should consider
changing that we should consider adding
something okay so we've got all kinds of
junk here
what funky stuff okay and notice you
have quite a few of Wolfram directories
there the last three lines you have
Wolfram Audio Wolfram audio capture
which was an older thing yes if you do
there's a bunch of crazy stuff there yep
I mean I don't care that I have junk in
here okay let's let's set this as an LCC
task to go figure out where things put
your stuff okay because I think we're
going to find out we can quite easily
standardize because we've got management
tools for dealing with the local object
store and that's a good start okay let's
talk about that makes sense right
yes and speech synthesized is basically
the same story as well
we were just worried about where to put
it exactly I don't think that's such a
terrible thing
I mean we could do experimental eyes and
change the automatic setting later if
that's all we're concerned about about
where to put it
I would let's try to resolve the
question of where to put it which I
think we can do and let's plan did the
experimental eyes this okay unless
there's something else about speech
synthesized you don't like no that's it
okay so if I say spectrogram of this
cool super cool okay I really would like
to see those and audio capture do
experimental eyes okay makes sense all
right is that all for you yes okay thank
you shadi all right thank you okay is
Fahim here from the east door I'm right
here
great how's the cookie store the cookie
store has policy issues and privacy
issues and that's why it is currently
experimental and what is the cookie
store recording it's supposed to if you
give it a filename it's supposed to save
your cookies between sessions and in the
previous discussion this was frowned
upon and that's why we have always kept
it non and experimental so Willman so
what does this - gives the location of
which to store information on persistent
cookies to be used by URL read so this
is something which is like the keyring
issue that true no not quite but similar
okay so I mean it's storing just like
you could store passwords yeah that's
right store cookies to reuse yeah so the
privacy issue is that it's stored in
plain text or yes precisely so it really
should be using the the keyring
mechanism or something because if it
could store it in the keyring we're all
good okay yeah probably
I'll have to see them play how hearing
works well keyring is currently a bit of
a mess because we we backed into
something
there is really a complicated issue of
encryption protocols and so okay and
then the other yes the other issue is
that because it's a text file multiple
kernel sessions I am not quite sure how
that would work out the modern way of
storing cookies is in database this is a
text file and do that that's why it
really is a fairly good-sized project
not a great very complicated one but it
I mean what's wrong with I mean
basically it's a key value store right
it's it this cookie this value isn't it
right but it's stored in a text file so
accessing the file from multiple kernels
might be an issue accessing us and
readwrite access yes
so the modern browsers use databases to
store cookies and it's that's an issue
for the keyring naturally as well and
that's that question about multiple
access which I don't think we discussed
in the keyring okay um
main point okay who's whose project
managing here I'm noting things down so
we should get project managers who deal
with each of these projects in here okay
who dealt with for him who dealt with
the cookie business it was between you
and I and there wasn't a lot of project
managers back then okay um well okay so
so I guess Brad Ashby is the person
dealing with the keyring can we make him
aware that this is a similar issue and
also highlight this business about
multiple access for the keyring I'll let
him know
ok all right so I agree cookie store has
to sadly remain an experimental cookie
store you can get all kinds of different
kinds of experimental cookies there let
me know try and make up more puns even
though I Pollock regenerate that's okay
all right let's talk about the mail
functionality stuff okay so this will
also remain in dear experimental simply
because of all the search
integrally uncertainty about what we
return from search precisely and that's
why it's experimental still I mean if I
did a mail server connect right now
yeah it should work I mean there's no
issue and what did you do in terms of
okay that's pretty cool
okay so Wow okay so then I should be
able to actually do I'm you know we
haven't been able to use this yet
alright and the issue is the speed and
there's a lot of good amount of work
that is needed to actually have it sort
of for for people to be using to use it
actually well so so for example here
let's see I mean this is quite beautiful
no it's not that good actually and this
isn't that good this is a this is a um
you know that's an attachment isn't it
yeah why did that do that okay and why
did that is that an unread message yes
okay well it's cool and I kind of agree
with you a copy to experimental eyes
sadly um incoming mail settings is that
part of the that's part of the world of
this system right yes it's part of the
system settings Aravind
oh gosh yeah that can't be made - that
can't work um that's really kind of wild
because this needs the keyring again the
same coming mail settings needs the
keyring yes
okay what about dollar mobile phone and
I I don't know what that is it isn't
yours
no okay whose is it
ROG whose is it let me take a quick look
I don't think that needs to stay
experimental I think that's perfectly
valid thing well I put it under male
functionality because it's not yeah it's
knitted on that under that like page so
but it's nothing to do with male okay
I'll look into it okay I think nobody
else knows about it the people who
worked on the Twilio service connection
which means allen and so on or people or
christian those guys would know about
that okay and I I don't see any reason
why send message a mobile phone should
stay experimental and I would recommend
they're not okay okay
okay was that everything for Fahim thank
you okay great nice to see you okay but
a yes you already hung up just out of
curiosity what what are you working on
right now I'm working on financial data
okay cool okay fine all right thank you
good okay
all right you might have to let them in
right and I think he might be waiting
for you to let him in
yeah isn't okay great hi Devendra okay
Roger will review the syntax which gives
the series specification before moving
so this should presumably be I mean will
this come to me in a Roger style design
review exactly yes okay
along with the other asymptotic solver
so version 12 we got to milk it see more
coming up actually rather so asymptotic
some asymptotic or solid value and
asymptotic solve from Adam what is that
incorrect sold do it fine asymptotic
solution of an algebraic equation I mean
like another series near singularity or
parametric solutions and cruel it is a
very nice function then it's very
documented so useful hold off everything
until we meet you for that meeting okay
all right I'm just I'm curiosity what is
asymptotic some do it finds an
asymptotic for some if you if you have
ref page you can look at but basically
it does thing they call a Maclaurin and
other things to get you know so I mean
this is still it's coming on along well
you need a week more maybe to get it all
this okay just just for curiosity let's
look at asymptotic sauce yes that's a
beautiful function the applications are
really wonderful over here okay let's
take a look all right just just to
improve our mood let's take a look at
this all right let me see yeah if you
want
okay so asymptotic solve oh that is
pretty cool yes I mean that's basically
solving and y equals zero right so it's
like a serious solution but it deals
with singularities and so on it's not
the idea yes
so it not require it to be a power
series of data but it to be it could do
to saw and that kind of stuff and yes it
can cope with pretty general algebraic
curves and things like you know
transmitted roots can now get a finite
version so
no it's cool why are these things called
asymptotic whatever relevant series
whatever that's but we realize that the
word asymptotic actually seems to have
allow us to have this more general kind
of solution you know like wkb or
whatever and those could be called
series but I think we just want to make
sure that we kind of don't have to chain
the name or you know restrict ourselves
because we didn't allow the most general
asymptotic non convergent kind of
behavior fair enough
so okay that's okay that's for that that
discussion this looks very cool okay
good anything else for Devendra here so
those will undoubtedly be experimental
eyes for twelve right okay so one more
thing that I think Roger is going to
decide on that but he wants to also have
a few more functions going on so we
might just hold off everything a little
bit not because yeah yeah okay not a
problem
there's so these these these are not
going to end up being experimental ever
probably eventually but we all be in the
system already pretty good they'd be
used nicely but we just want to have
enough time okay Steven can you jump to
file operations next because we don't
have the developers for the next next to
you here okay we don't have the folks
for chat what is control objects anyway
this is just one function form control
and the chat thing is still such a mess
okay let's go to file operations okay
why do you want to keep file system app
experimental so the main reason is that
we'd haven't sorted out a good way of
how to handle functions that evaluate on
directories and on files it's a file
system map we currently operate on files
we scan through whatever the directory
level that you specify is but the
problem is in returning the nest of
associations we don't have a good way to
indicate this is the result of the
evaluation on this directory and this is
the evaluation on the file and within
each directory so it's not really an
evaluation problem it's a
output problem if we want to have
filesystem map be able to evaluate on
directories as well as the files within
them
I understand didn't we have an option
for filesystem map to get it to also
look at directories that was one of the
things that we were looking at doing
right now we don't have that because we
don't know how to make the output work
reasonably you know the the idea being
that each of the the directory is the
key for another Association and each
file is a key with the value of the
evaluation on it and if we want
basically if you have a parent directory
that you evaluate file date on and then
there a bunch of files inside that
directory that you also evaluated file
dates on how do we indicate that this is
the file date for the entire directory
without sort of overriding the
individual file results and it turns out
most of our file operations actually
work on both date or on files and
directories ok ok ok so so the issue
here is that um let's see so in this
case this is a directory right yes that
is a directory and then ok so the issue
is that the self we don't know how to
indicate that this did the file
for that directory is something we have
no I understand we don't know because
because right now the only place the
directory appears is as that Association
key key correct yeah I mean so you know
like like one way to do it which would
be very UNIX C is to say you know dot
arrow whatever right here mm-hmm we
thought about using dot or self or
identity but none of them really seemed
to be you know dow is fine in sort of a
UNIX yeah that's a thing I mean those
are string names then a better thing
would be to use a symbol right because
we don't want to confuse you know if you
happen to have a file in that directory
called automatic then well but not but
this would be a symbol anyway right if
we use a symbol then it's a little
clearer I mean inherited might be there
but even that's pretty weird yeah and
you know directory is a symbol but it no
absolutely feel about the general
structure of what we're getting here I
mean that is you know I think we've
generally been happy with it the sort of
default idea of you get this set of
nested associations that mirrors what
exists on the file system but you can
also squish things down if you want and
flatten it you know functionally we
haven't really had a problem with file
system map or file system scan doesn't
have this issue because it doesn't
produce output that I thought it would
be weird if we do experimental eyes scan
but Liang has done ok the hold on let's
let's just address the issue here ok so
first of all do we have an option
anywhere else for allowing directories
in other words but for considering
directories and I believe it is an
include directories maybe not
directory create intermediate
directories and things like file names
re they don't really make a strong
distinction between directories and
files unless you're using a pattern for
it yeah you know it occurred to me that
something that I want to do all the time
is make a list of files in a directory
why don't we have a function this was
called file list so we had looked at the
the basic problem ends up being that for
you know a basic operation we say give
me the list of files that are in this
directory it works as soon as we start
trying to add extra parameters to say
give me files that you know have this
name it basically turns into a clone of
file names you know the the slightly
funny thing about file names is that it
defaults to looking at your current
working directory which is why a lot of
the single argument forms end up being
weird otherwise you could say file names
of give a directory name and look at the
gonna file names to look at the current
directory is not you know star dot you
know C or something stupid right it's
it's not stupid to do that it's just
it's what makes it slightly more
cumbersome in terms of saying I want all
the files in this directory is you need
to say you know asterisks comma the
directory you actually want I know
by the way does all Wilkens well I
believe it does I believe all is a alias
for the wild-card string oops
if it does yeah and I believe it's
documented and we were trying to promote
the usage of that over the wild card
string looks like that hasn't been moved
up oh that will check on that after this
meeting yeah I figured be useful even to
give it in this top-level area here
mm-hmm that's stupid there just say or
file names of all yeah the next bullet
is the same thing but it needs to be
condensed yes I think it should also be
up in the top here mm-hmm okay yeah I
would argue that we just put it file
names of all commodore here a list of
all all files okay um fine okay so I'm
I'm I'm off the plan of having at that
specific file so I mean the issue then
what was the idea with the web crawler
of what it's returning it's trying to
return a structure that's the same kind
of general shape as file system map
right
that was a that's a Nicholas thing maybe
we could somebody see if I can get
Nicholas may come across like my old
cherry fetching sander on our live
stream is suggesting the name parent I'm
not sure that's quite the right thing
cause I mean basically what it is it's
the directory named arrow and then the
directory name as an association key
arrow and then file one arrow whatever
and then the question is what's the boy
weird thing I mean what's the self thing
here yeah I mean we'd also briefly
talked about having you know if you we
wanted to evaluate we could have the the
directory be the key but then it doesn't
necessarily point directly to an
association it could be a list and an
association but there it's really um you
know the other person who'd be wonderful
if we could see if we can find them as
is Jose who could talk about how the
tree representation relates to this okay
if we can't find these folks okay we
can't find the folks now then we should
postpone this for a bit but I I would
love to solve this problem this seems
like a you know just a little design
nugget that we happen to be well um once
we sorted out these are basically done
yeah it's just it's something I haven't
had a lot of time to devote much thought
to so if we if we can get a few people
together and sort of hammer out what a
reasonable way to do that is we can
basically clear all these off I just
thought it would be weird to D
experimental eyes some of them without
solving this problem right no I agree
car laying on the livestream as saying
that filesystem map makes me think it's
a map type function which it is mm-hmm
there's nothing non that be about it
that I know of I mean the the main
difference is that instead of giving an
explicit list you give a directory and
it generates the list of files from it
right so it's implicitly mapping over
the this collection of people in okay hi
Nicholas hi Jose cuz I'm hey we are
talking about filesystem map and we're
trying to understand some things about
its structure yeah in particular the
issue is file system map doesn't have a
good way if we had an include
directories option and we have some
function that is being applied to
directories themselves as well as to
their file contents we don't have a good
way to return results that relate to the
directory because the directory is right
now just being used
as an association key so my question
first to Nicholas is in what we're doing
with with what are we calling it is it
web what is it called web crawl
what is the function that way we're
setting up for web crawling easy because
the web directory is it's an entity on
its own right I'm sorry you're saying it
is or is not an and today it is with
everything that it's not like a this is
different walk me through that so in the
case of the web what does this return I
mean did you're saying it isn't sub but
it does have subdirectories doesn't it
the thing we're returning yes it's
considered a directory but it's an HTTP
object everything else I see okay butBut
so but when you return stuff so if you
look at filesystem map one feature of
filesystem map is it is returning this
is a really weird installation directory
if you have a chance now you have the
main issues we wanted an example that
will work when anyone evaluates it no I
know that but just put an installation
directory for wall from desktop instead
okay um okay but but in any case the
point here is that we've got this thing
um okay do you have a hierarchical form
like this one nicolas for the web crawl
stuff no not at all
so it's just a list of urls is that
correct and cross anything it can to do
and it and it and you your function will
be called up will be applied to each URL
or whether it's
whether it ends also doesn't know but I
understand the whole point is that file
system map can represent the hierarchy
of the file system by a nested set of
associations you're saying that that's
not true as well correct the web crawl
map will return only a flat list of URL
error values because not always strictly
our G no I understand it's doing Messier
so in this case it's like infinity for
the last argument for the our argument
here which gives know what is the
subdirectories down the level n are
represented by an association what is
what is the one here that there's oh I
see with with zero what is the case
where that last argument is zero then it
will be it will flatten it out
correct yeah system out of file date or
file size um is it file size of fire
byte count file size installation
directory okay so if I do the default of
that it will be one level where yep okay
if I do two levels there then it will
show me presumably oh boy it's huge it
will show me some directory so at the
one level case it doesn't even show me
the directories for the hair right
because it's the directory itself the
installation directory is basically the
implied key that Association no I
understand up but but there are no sub
keys here I could have a key for the
add-ons directory hmm right where I
don't go inside it I only see the
directory and it's the value of the
function applied to the whole directory
mm-hmm yes we were to include
directories in the evaluation so we
could say include directory
and at the leaf level it's pretty clear
what to do right okay so the issue is so
I think include directories so there's
an option include directories that makes
sense to have mm-hmm
that just determines whether at the
leaves you include directories make
sense yeah whether okay then the next
question is at the non leaves how do we
represent the value of the function
applied to the directories and first
point what Nicolas is claiming is that
you never do this hierarchical thing for
the web you could naturally good okay so
if I do that what does zero do what is
what do I need to do do i do infinity
there together so I think you want to do
one to flatten it down right that's so R
is the level associated with it so it's
basically zero do that as well I guess
yeah I guess I wasn't as sure in terms
of what we wanted to do in handling of a
zero level specification since it
usually refers back to the head I see i
I think zero should do that but but okay
but so in the web case this is the kind
of output you're generating Nicolas is
that correct yes okay okay so look
include directories I'm not sure that's
the right name for it
for the leaf thing it's clearly a
worthwhile option Yeah right next
question is in the intermediate now
notice that we already had an option
called include intermediate directories
which is some other didn't we
what was that thing about intermediate
directories create intermediate
directories for you okay that's that's
for some copy file mechanism mm-hmm yeah
okay
all right so now the next question is so
now there's a question about trees so
question for Jose
um do we have
is there a natural way to take this
nested set of associations and make it
into a tree there isn't there it's an
expression it's the expression tree
function if I'm not mistaken
yeah yes I think so it's a function that
knows what to do explicitly with
associations yes okay is it build yet eh
I think this yes maybe it's on trees um
do we need to say needs trees no nothing
unless I think that's the prototype
build I'm running here oh no no no no
it's not the prototype okay let me let
me get the prototype hold for a second
um because what I want to see is how
would the tree handle how would the tree
the tree element thing will correctly
handle having things I mean because
because arguably file system map could
actually return a tree as well that
could be another thing that it can
return actually arguably we might want a
function called file system tree or is
that crazy because we have a thing that
does tree map right that that map's a
function over the nodes of a tree
silence don't we have that I don't
remember right now okay I think we do
have that so let's take this okay now
let's say expression tree file system
graph may be a better name the file
system tree really I think
that little bizarre creature purports to
be the tree yes it's this is our very
flat
lots of yeah yeah right okay but now at
the nodes so do you understand what I'm
saying we've got this notion of tree
element which operates you know where we
can actually attach data to the nodes
right yes um but here we don't have a
method in the nested associations so if
I had a tree that had things attached to
its nodes and I did expression tree
expression what would it do
how would it return the nested
Association from that does that make any
sense
well the payload is interpreted as the
head so it's going to create something
as the head of there so so the payload
is the head of the expression and then
the leaves chorus of trees will be the
arguments of that head I see I see I see
is that something completely crazy from
this from this point of view well maybe
let me see so there's no what about is
there an association a tree Association
thing that will go to NASA's associate I
don't think so no no there is not such a
thing it is expression tree or tree
expression that know what to do with
associations explicitly because they
will use the keys as some labels for the
arrows connecting each other yes but in
the case of the left hand side because
the directories are frequently treated
as files
perhaps there is a notion of the action
of the directory has been interpreted as
a file for some functions yeah I
understand the problem is that that if
we're going to give a property like this
is a file size here we're gonna grow a
property of the directory itself if it's
a leaf we know how to do it but if it's
a an intermediate node it's not clear
how to indicate the property of that
intermediate node as opposed to one of
the leaf nodes yes but what I mean is
that there is a case in which you don't
want to enter a directory but you still
want to know the full size of that
directory and then there is a case of
you enter the directory and then you are
giving them but so we've got a mechanism
I think for not going very deep so the
directories are leaves but then we you
know give the properties the directory I
think there will be some kind of a clue
directories then the case the case that
we don't know is so we know how to solve
that one the case we don't know how to
solve it's when there's an intermediate
node that has a property of the
intermediate node right in addition to
the properties of the leaves because
right now the only thing that has a
property here is the leaf I see and what
about introducing some sort of token as
a key like like the deal itself or
something that that
we thought about that it's a possibility
um yeah I think that's the best thing we
just need to name it boy we've been
avoiding a cell for so long I mean all
inherited I mean all is probably the
least crazy that I can immediately think
of because it does refer to the whole
directory but now does that really work
because if we have two levels of this so
let's say we have a arrow another level
of directory B arrow and then the files
f1 etc etc right yep so now
I don't quite get it so a br oh I see
that's a that's there will be an all
together with f1 and another one
together would be yeah that's right I
think that's the least crazy thing we've
come up with him
NIC your comments yeah I mean I think it
makes sense I'm just trying to think for
pretty much any case all makes sense you
know file size certainly make sense to
say all because it's effectively the sum
of all of the components finally I note
you know what the inode is or something
it it's a little funky to call it all
but it's not completely crazy right I'm
just taking a quick look at what
functions we have there are some
functions we have that will operate on
directories and files and vice versa but
the majority of functions that work on
file system expressions work on either
well parent directory is a little bit
clunky I guess that works on the file as
well yeah all right colonies directory
we can't do that dialogue directory if
it was a new symbol what makes it will
evaluate that and we don't have that I
know we don't have it but it should we
should if we had it it would evaluate I
see it's a dollar symbol I should have
that makes sense yeah an object what
kind directory object file object that
contains the metadata instead of putting
that as the value mm I don't think
that's great idea I mean in other words
you're suggesting that the head be
decorated I mean that the key be
decorated here I don't think that's a
great idea for these purposes look I
think let's plan on this and the issue
is do we have include directories as a
single option
um or do we wanna differentiate do we
want to differentiate the directories as
leaves I mean in a sense like I said
yeah it's the question of do you
evaluate on all directories are only at
the deepest level yeah and you could
have true/false automatic and automatic
is only the Leafs that's not terrible
and in the case of true we do the old
decoration we do the all decoration and
does that mean that at the deepest level
we want it to just give the value as if
it's a leaf or do we want it to actually
create a dirt okay yep no we want to
give it the value so we just want to
name it as directory blah blah blah
arrow and then the function applied to
the directory right okay yeah we don't
want to it makes sense we have a level
spec we don't want to change the
dimensionality just because we can
handle the intermediate nodes in a
different fashion it's still right okay
yep so I think true arguably I mean
there is actually another case which is
the case where you want the intermediate
ones but you don't want the deepest
level or is that a silly case I don't
know of a usage scenario where it would
be the case but I mean that doesn't cry
you can also imagine you know a list nm
include directories for them I think
that would make sense all right what
Nick why don't you see if you can get
you know think this through in more
detail and we're gonna prototype version
of it and we'll be good
yep and then let's look at that and then
hopefully we can get experimental eyes
this guy for 412 oh okay yep
[Music]
and yeah it doesn't it doesn't affect
file name forms or file system scans so
if we're good there then those other two
can come along for the ride sounds good
okay um resource system next Steven okay
I think we're kind of running out of
time but okay who here who needs to
stick around here for resource system
bad this here okay and Brad Parrish be
great okay so I think I can leave okay
thank you yeah you know you don't need
to stick around thank you bye um okay
resource system so we've got a lot of
stuff already the experimental eyes
right yeah by the way Sandra on our live
stream was suggesting a wrapper of some
kind for unfortunately we are not in a
good position to have a directory
wrapper because we already have this
unfortunate function called directory
that returns a directory unless we did
something really and kind of
I don't think that will really help us
actually because um it won't really help
us that would it to decorate it with the
directory rapper will only help in the
case where we're distinguishing which we
don't particularly think we need to do
between a directory within a within a
directory so to speak and an individual
file within a directory I mean that's a
distinction we might be interested in
making but I think that's yet another
level of distinction which we can after
all make in the in the payload and the
right-hand side of the results from
applying the function okay let's talk
briefly about the resource system then
we got to wrap this up um let's see yeah
resource search definitely changing yep
I'm unconvinced about resource removed
being there at all
I agree especially now that we have
delete object I think we should
deprecated it I just I yeah
delete object is the same thing so right
just make sure delete objects probably
properly documented ok resource submit
and the publisher ID business do we
really want to call it publisher ID as
opposed to resource publisher ID are
there any things we're gonna publish and
I guess we have cloud publish which is
confusing I think so I could see this
changing in the near future
I just don't think we've properly
debugged that system I mean have we have
people been using resource submit yet
only internally really I think maybe
maybe half a dozen external people we've
only issued it a couple of extra
publisher eighties right well it's a
challenge for folks on the live stream
to start submitting resources and to
actually get publisher IDs and to start
using resource submit yeah these these
functions seem a little bit embryonic
right now it's also presumably resource
submit can take a whole notebook right
can take the submission notebook for the
data repository or whatever else I
should and a resource object can take
the notebook so you might need a second
wrappers that'd be trivial to set that
up you know okay do that automatically
well right fine okay so I think this
this is not ready for primetime resource
update
yeah I saw there I think there are
options possibly even additional
arguments that will be added at some
point for a version for your manual
version is that that's a incorrectly
typeset thing should be fixed yeah
that's just template input error it
looks like probably my fault but yeah I
think you know we have sort of automatic
version control that does the right
thing for 95% of what people want but I
think we'll want to extend this to allow
more manual control well okay there's
also the question of the patent update
system I mean since we're we're now
making padlets ready for primetime
um right so that will also have an
update mechanism and so we might want to
merge the update mechanisms for these
things
well definitely need to make sure they
play well together yes and we had a
conversation with John that makes me
think some of the stuff might change
significantly in the to medium future a
significant ufff to keep it from being
all right fine experiment so let's not
do experimental eyes these okay all
right I think that's everything on the
resource system so nothing nothing can
get the experimentalist at this time
okay
I'm just looking ahead here I'm going to
guess theorem proving is going to go
fairly easily I think scheduled tasks I
have no idea why there's even other
things parental there at all oh all that
stuff Wow I'm pretty sure that's ready
to be experimental eyes Raj do you know
anything about that
well Constantine wants it to be
experimental probably for one more
version I think why I have no idea why
he I think he's probably confused um so
let's have a discussion with him if we
need it we should make sure Tom is on
call for that discussion
I'm 90% certain he's confused
I mean his main concern was that he
doesn't have enough use cases to be e to
feel comfortable enough to the
experimental eyes I mean it's not yeah I
I don't think it's not his expertise to
figure that out and then there is
apparently a known issue about
insufficient support of time
specifications which still needs to be
refined but that's an implementation
issue right okay right I'll get
everything else in in the next meeting
okay okay sounds good okay
yeah this is almost certainly ready th
parental ice I don't know what enough Y
enough somebody thinks it isn't okay it
needs to be that needs to be
non-experimental 412 okay we can we can
probably address that in the next
meeting sounds good
okay well thank you all thanks to folks
on the live stream and onto the next
thing
all right y'all later okay bye bye